maybe first let's talk about your
reaction to uh interest rates not moving
yesterday i know you were pretty bullish
on it being a buy the news type event
which it seems to have been the market
had been de-risking over the last couple
weeks right and so
whenever you have some kind of node
event like this um you know generally
people the framework i'm going to talk
about people generally apply to like uh
buy the buy the room or sell the news
right where you have you know kind of
the insider's getting in first
information comes out you know the kind
of works its way down the informational
you know totem pole or human centipede
of information by the time it gets to
the end when the event comes there's no
new buyers because everyone's already
buying in anticipation of this event
right and so um my kind of thesis over
the last few days and you know this kind
of why i texted you is like
what i what i was thinking was kind of
this reverse
in the sense of you know you're selling
the room or buying the news because
everyone's already de-risking and then
by the time you get to the event right
that everyone's saying is going to be
bearish because they've all risked off
heading into it
who are going to be the sellers left and
i think that we kind of saw that
yesterday where um you know the fed was
slightly more you know
hawkish than i kind of expected them to
be but you know i i think um you know
the only the only real sellers that
would have stepped in yesterday are
people that um you know had had been
expecting the fed not to raise rates um
and and somehow that would affect their
crypto you know thesis
and so you know yesterday i wasn't
really surprised to see that kind of be
this this by the you know by the news
event um if you will um
and so yeah i mean i i wasn't you know
all too surprised at all by the reaction
that we got um you know as well um you
know leading up to that we also saw a
couple other kind of telltale signs but
just from like a fundamental perspective
you know i think um
just you know doing some thinking as to
like you know sometimes you just it's as
simple as thinking like okay who are
going to be the buyers or sellers for
this event um and so conversely like you
know the opposite of this would have
been like
you know the uh the coinbase you know
which was you know the absolute in the
coinbase ipo which was the absolute you
know pico top on april 14th so for some
of these events um you know sometimes
it's not entirely obvious you know
sometimes um sometimes you'll say okay i
know there's going to be some kind of
reaction
but not you know sure exactly you know
where it's going to break for example
like i think coinbase was a better
example in that case where it wasn't so
clear but um you know once we started to
see the market break a certain direction
then you know you would have um you know
then become cautious but you know this
during this specific event i think it
was pretty clear that you know just
thinking about
who where the sellers can be left it's
really hard to you know think that you
know the majority of those who are going
to do risk hadn't already done so
all right one of the things that i saw
that you pulled up we've got a couple of
charts here uh that i think is
absolutely fascinating is that even
though the price has been drawing down
we've got this purpose bitcoin etf uh it
looks like people are still putting
assets into this thing so what is this
showing us right we're just looking at
the holdings of uh the purpose bitcoin
etf which is a spot etf in canada
and what we've seen over the last two
weeks is their holdings have actually um
and by the way you know i haven't done
the newsletter this week so i might mess
up some numbers here because i'm not
reading off my newsletter but i think
they've added about 240 million dollars
of btc in the last two weeks uh during
this drawdown which is anything that's
going to significantly move the market
right but um you know at the same time
it you know it's
it's just more of a um you know a sign
to see that there is still hunger from
you know people looking to to you know
buy bitcoin and um you know likely uh
you know institutional or kind of
traditional investors that are going to
buy through an etf versus just you know
take custody of their bitcoin so um you
know i just think that's a kind of a
promising sign in terms of looking at
you know like institutional flows if you
will um you know
we i think in total now they hold like
one and a half billion dollars of btc um
and you know this is just uh something
for gary gensler to look at and see you
know there's definitely an appetite for
you know spot pick when etf
all right then when we start to look at
the supply shock ratios we've been
talking about these for months and
months and months and months now uh back
in june and july a lot of people uh will
remember that you explicitly highlighted
this idea of a bullish divergence you've
got it labeled on this chart here uh
when you look at this is it happening
again like how do you look at this and
what is this telling us
totally so um you know first of all just
before we get into the specific chart
you know the way i'm the way i'm looking
at um and this kind of evolves is the
way i see this is like on chain is macro
right so we have that kind of giving you
the underlying like broader current of
the market and then we can look at
things like you know order books or
derivatives data which is extremely
important on the shorter term time
frames and then price action is kind of
our confirmation of that um so with that
being said right now we have a bullish
divergence between
the liquid supply shock ratio and price
which means that we're seeing supply
moving to uh long-term investors or
entities that have very low spending
history meaning they take in and hold at
least three out of every four coins that
they take in
and this is this is very different to
what we saw over may or or in may i
should say um in may you saw this
decline as we kind of had this relief
bounce if you will
um and at the time you know if you had
this metric you definitely would have
wanted to be cautious right because
you're seeing supply moving from enemies
that were previously strong hands to now
becoming weakened so supply moving from
entities who take in and hold most of
their coins that are now becoming those
weak handed entities or liquid or highly
liquid enemies
and so there's a kind of a key
difference between that and kind of the
underlying
structure of what's going on in the
market right now you don't have
fundamental investors that are currently
turning into weak hands this was also
reflected in um and this is kind of a
good segue to the chart i sent it's uh
net unreal i'm sorry net realized uh
profit loss
and so
on kind of a similar note what you'll
see here is that currently
investors are realizing profits i'm
sorry realizing losses more than profits
which just means that you have supply
that was previously bought overhead
is now being sold you know at these
price levels so you know people that
essentially bought the top are now
capitulating down here
uh versus you know fundamental investors
that bought in you know a long time ago
that are now deciding that this is some
kind of fair value for them to solve
their btc um you have more so it's kind
of capitulation from top buyers i mean
that especially happened uh last week as
you can see that big big spike down and
we've kind of been progressively making
you know higher lows in that meaning
that uh the kind of the amount of uh
realized losses is you know subsiding
you know meaning that the kind of
capitulation is slowing um and so that
that's kind of a ties into the previous
chart i looked at meaning and what i'm
just trying to say out of all this is
that
the sellers that we've had recently so
initially we had this large drawdown
right because we had all these over
leveraged longs um and then you know
recently we we've just had people kind
of capitulating and that's been getting
absorbed by long-term investors and
we're just kind of in this range right
for the past two weeks we've just talked
about last week i said i'm a crowd
market maximalist right um we're just
you know we're just chilling in this
range uh and you know until until we
have some kind of clear break and in my
opinion that's defined as you know
getting above and holding 53k
or below 40k for the very scenario um
you know until we break either of those
kind of uh you know
you know invalidation points um you know
i think we're still just ranging right
and and so like it's really easy to get
you know chopped up in these ranges you
know i see like twitter sentiment it's
like we get to the top of the range and
everyone thinks we're going to the moon
we get to the bottom and everyone's
saying we're going to zero um this is
like the same thing that happened over
summer right like every time we got down
to like 30k everyone's like oh my god
you know 20k you know this is it or
we're going to zero
every time we get to the top of the
range especially when they had like with
that one move up to like 40k everyone
got like insanely bullish
um you know i think i think it's really
important to just have these like kind
of key
uh you know invalidation points that
kind of say okay yeah we're you know
we've either you know broke into the
upside or downside of the range um and
to me that's that's 53k which we'll get
into in a second um as well as 40 40k to
the downside i think like you you
definitely don't want to lose um 40k for
the balls i think uh though you know
that would i you know i've been cautious
since since we you know had all the
derivatives piled up and especially
after we broke below 53 because i said
that was kind of like uh my my you know
uptrend uh kind of cut off for bitcoin
um but you know definitely you know if
we if we broke 40 40k that you know be
pretty bearish um but you know to say
that we've gotten back out of this range
uh which has been kind of called between
you know 42 and 52k
i'd be looking for a break and hold
above 53 which we can talk about in a
second as to a couple different reasons
why i think that's the case